stephen what's up brother hey how's it
going what do you got for me tonight
well i'm just i feel like i'm stuck man
it's like uh i got a good job
i got my side business going too and
it's like
like
like i know i'm not alpha i
i admit that i'm not an alpha but
i just ordered your book and just just
to see like 2022 i need to
something's got to change
all right what are you stuck on so
what's not working for you
huh
so what are you stuck on so what's not
working for you
well i keep uh like
all these single moms they keep coming
after me and it's like is that all i can
get
and all the women
all the women from when i
uh that rejected me before college are
coming back to are coming to me now so
it's like
where were you when i was coming up so
and let me guess they're coming at you
with some other mofos kids and toes too
right yeah yeah so so how old are you
i'm 34.
you're 34. you got any kids yourself
excuse me
do you have any kids yourself oh no no
no no i avoided that as much as i could
and is my volume low can you guys hear
me okay
uh maybe it's me uh having a little
trouble hearing you
guys in the chat uh moff and jiren let
me know if my volumes are i thought you
sound much better now all right um
dude it's simple like the older you get
the more women that you're gonna come
across that have kids in tow from prior
relationships some are gonna have
several from several different guys
and they're really just looking for
captain save a whole they've already had
their fun right
so i mean like you treat them like how
you want to treat them if you just want
to treat them as a friends with benefits
then you keep them at that length you
don't invite them into your life right
if um
if what you're looking for is it is a
woman without red flags and has a
positive traits of green flags like what
are you worth as a man yourself today
right like at 36 have you got your life
sorted you have your money sorted you
own your own place like where are you at
with your life right now well i'm 34. uh
i'm an engineer
uh i make
make uh six figures by myself i'm trying
to get my own rentals going on so i can
make uh passive income also so i'm
pretty well
established on my own you know i'm just
looking to start a family
i don't see like much fat on your face
like you fit
i was just doing 12 hour shifts so i let
myself go a little bit but uh i look
like me
i look like vinnie
no
oh yeah okay all right so like
you're a higher value guy right yeah i
think that you already know that you
tall
uh five eight i mean tall enough tall
enough
if you said that you know you know that
you were like five five i'd be like dude
you're gonna have to get rid of some of
that body fat and get jacked because if
you're not that tall you're gonna have
to work every other area max it out
right like there's guys out there that
are 5 8 that do just fine so that's not
that big of a deal for you right you got
most of your life together all you have
to do dude is just understand okay like
what what else can you do to improve
life you know you've got your uh
engineer gig going on you're working on
some rental income you know you're
working on your little hustles you know
to build up your life
the thing that you got to be really
careful with now is that you don't do
something stupid like an invite a woman
in your life that's got like three kids
from three different fathers because you
want to play captain save a hoe move
them into your house pay off their debt
and then two or three years down the
road when you know you hear f you you're
not my father you can't tell me what to
do then she wants to take you for
support on the kids that aren't even
yours that's what you got to be really
careful with i i actually
experienced that right and
and thank god i did not get myself
trapped and get her pregnant and i like
my dad was telling me this he was like
don't do it don't do it and
me yeah me being a knucklehead i did it
and luckily thank god i got myself out
good that is now i'm like you know what
no more single mothers i i just
like i don't get them out there dude
like i'll be honest with you there's
going to be a lot of that that you're
going to come across them
you know you want to set up an fwb
arrangement with them cool right but
just don't invite them in your life
don't you know
get introduced to the kids or any of
those things just state younger women
man or just date women that don't have
kids right
i mean at your age you could easily date
23 year old
i'm trying man
maybe it's me i don't know where to go
stuff like that but i'm trying to put
myself out there more are you are you
captivating are you a captivating guy do
you have fun stuff that you like to do
um
i i honestly i wouldn't say so i mean i
do brazilian jiu jitsu
uh i run
a little archery sometimes you know i'm
trying to get myself out there more okay
so like i would i would go looking for
hobbies and interests that you know you
can do that you like to do
but also invite a woman to come and do
with you because that's interesting
right like i had a conversation with a
guy once he's like you know i'm just
really struggling with loaded guy good
looking you know for his age and his you
know for his category probably like top
you know two to three percent sort of
male like the top echelons but he was
boring you know like he didn't have
anything to do with women on on dates
you know to keep them entertained where
do you live like what part of the
country
uh i live in georgia i'm i'm originally
from new york
i moved down to georgia for work okay so
i'm in uh mcdonough georgia okay so i
don't know georgia that well i mean i've
driven through it a few times coming
down to florida but it's mostly in the
middle of night and i'm doing like 250
kilometers an hour and in the future
so i don't i don't spend a lot of time
there except for gas stations so i don't
know what's around but um like you know
to kind of segue back to this guy's
story he he wasn't that interesting now
he liked off-roading and he had a
decked-out jeep right with all the stuff
on it i said to him i go why don't you
take some you know take your date out in
the desert and do some baja like [ __ ]
you know
grab some drinks and a picnic or a
cheese platter and you know throw it out
when you can stop somewhere on one of
the high ledges or something like that
right like you have to do something
that's fun and entertaining like you can
do anything to a woman that you want
literally like
guys have gotten away with banging their
girlfriend's best friend and she won't
leave right she'll just look the other
way and be like i love you i'm not gonna
don't worry about it just don't let it
happen again i've never had that
literally do anything to a woman except
for bore them
okay so you have to make sure that
you're engaging that you're captivating
and that you've got interesting things
to invite gorgeous women in to come and
do with you right like i i'm an engineer
for airline so i can pretty much take
them anywhere in the world on a flight
you mean yeah okay so
i mean that wouldn't be my advice for
like a
like a couple of dates sort of thing
but that could be something later on
down the road right but you know if you
have an interest that you like and you
want to go and explore then invite her
along let's go to
whatever yellowstone national park and
check out yeah why or whatever right so
you've got that option for you so
do something that's captivating right
like say like one of the things that you
know we often talk about in the group is
like
you know if you're gonna run game and
you're gonna date women you have to have
a good instagram like you have to have a
solid hey my life is captivating it's
interesting these are the things that i
like to do right it just makes it easier
for you yeah well i mean there's all
these little things that just make
things easier for you that
there's a book that i read a long time
ago it's called inbound marketing
and it's really a book for entrepreneurs
to help them like build their business
and their audience and have their
customers come come to them
you can take the same concepts from that
book and apply it to dating women right
by putting out the right things out
there that you know it's like when you
go fishing you drop some lures in the
water you know with the right bait on it
sort of thing that's all that an
instagram is it's bait
okay
seriously it's it's it's just bait
that's like hey i'm steven pierre jerome
and i've got an interesting life here's
where i was last week and this is where
i'm going next week and you can see me
in the story doing this cool thing over
here with these interesting people and
there's some pretty women looking at me
while i'm doing them sort of thing like
you see what i'm saying right yeah like
there's these little things that you can
do and i'm not saying do it
to get the girls i'm saying you know run
your life and live it in such a way that
you're doing interesting things that you
happen to capture those moments and you
just drop it on the gram sort of thing
to let them know that you're a cool dude
and like women will literally look at
your instagram like they creep the [ __ ]
out of guys like you guys out there have
no idea the kinds of [ __ ] that i've
caught women doing on social media oh
dude dude
one day one day i'm gonna tell all it's
gonna have to be like a private
conversation because i can't put that
[ __ ] on youtube
but they but they creep the [ __ ] out of
that stuff like they'll look at the
likes they'll click through they'll see
who's liking it oh she's pretty why
would she's why was she liking stefan
stuff right they make it easy for you
all you have to do is just
i'm interesting drop some stuff and then
let the uh hamster get caffeinated you
know the meatball between the rears you
let the hamster on the
little hamster wheel running around it
gets caffeinated and starts thinking
about [ __ ] and it's like all of a sudden
your value goes from here up to here
right okay these are just like the small
things that you can tweak that that will
make your life more interest more
interesting more captivating what i
would recommend that you do actually uh
stefan um moff can you drop your link
for the uh show you guys are doing
afterwards i don't know if you're doing
it on youtube or on stereo but um i'm
pretty much at the 90 minute mark okay
so here you go so he's going to put it
on on stereo uh maf and jiren like to do
an after show
here it is here you just download this
app it's called stereo
just put them off after it and then
you'll get onto the show and they'll do
some q a with you guys as well uh jaren
and moth
run game constantly
right so if you want to start asking
them questions about
how to how to run your instagram and how
to signal value sort of stuff like that
i'm starting to run out of time like i
only have gas for about a 90-minute show
[Laughter]
so i let these guys take off
you see what i'm saying but like
yeah like dude like you're fine you just
have to be more discerning in your taste
you have to signal that you're an
interesting captivating guy that you do
cool [ __ ] and again you're not doing it
to get to girls you're doing it because
it just
you know improves your life like if you
like archery
right join an archery club right like
are you part of an archery club
uh i'm doing it by myself right now yeah
uh the only club type thing i do is
brazilian jiu jitsu which you really
can't you know like that's interesting
to women because she knows that you can
[ __ ] somebody up
but she's not going to want to roll with
you right like you know you're not going
to fold her in her clothes somebody once
said to me you know the thing about bjj
like the best way to define it is
folding clothes with a person in it
yeah
you see what i'm saying but i mean like
the thing with the archery like you
could bring a woman along to do archery
right or if you have a crossbow if
there's a club that you can go to
right and then you can demonstrate your
skills right yes if got sharp skills
that you know that they're getting there
you see what i'm saying
yeah okay
okay
i'm gonna try that uh my my biggest
thing is like
like i'm really trying to force myself
to come up my shell like hey like
like like you said with the instagram
uh i only got nine posts
nine posts i got so um jaren can you can
you post your gram in the uh chat i know
that you're gonna get extra followers
from it but i think that jaren's is
probably one of the better better
examples out there excuse me
um let me see if i can actually maybe i
can pull it up here on my desktop in
case he doesn't get it there
but uh
there we go
let's see
i i don't want to say i'm a beta i think
i'm right in the middle somewhere but
can a a guy like me become an alpha to
like
dude you're gonna come over the [ __ ] you
want
uh
all right so there's his uh gram so
if you want a good example of how to
signal you know like a captivating
interesting life
here i can put it up on the screen too
just
save you guys a trouble i mean you know
you can go creep them if you want later
but
that's my boy right like he's you know
you know he can play the guitar he's
here with some cool guys he's fighting
over here with moth
right you know you got a mystery pick
over here with the back of the head and
shoulder sort of thing and here's a cute
one with a kid sort of thing you get the
idea right yeah you know he's doing
stuff with his life he's not doing it to
get the girls he's doing it because he
genuinely likes to do it it's just you
happen to you know capture some of those
moments and you hit the gram and that's
it and i guarantee like you know if you
hit any one of these over here and i'm
just going to creep you right now buddy
because anybody can do this because it's
all public right but look at all the
girls on this checking this out
right dude's got game you know there's a
lot of guys in here you know that he's
boys with but there's a lot of women on
here that are checking this [ __ ] out
right you see what i'm saying yeah you
get the idea and it just makes your life
easier right like that's what i'm
talking about when i'm talking about in
in bound marketing is you know you just
go live your life you do cool [ __ ] you
capture it let let it go out there and
then let the women
kind of caffeinate the hamsters in their
head because girls will like it there's
a girl you're dating she sees other
girls liking that competition anxiety
kicks in all of a sudden steven doesn't
look like a seven anymore now he looks
like an eight and a half
right yeah yeah
just caffeinate the hamster man makes it
makes your job easier so that you can go
out there and do your engineering thing
chase excellence you know buy real
estate put renters in it right
yeah
definitely definitely yeah there's
there's there's more to chop up but why
don't you hop on the uh boys stereo show
afterwards and uh you know ask him a few
questions to get some more insight on it
so stereo
right yeah just download the app stereo
and then look for moff
copy that all right man see ya
you